our first guest though knows a thing or
two about bestselling albums he's so
incredibly talented he sold over 75
million worldwide and won five Grammys
no big deal but now he's got a whiskey
it's called Fraser and Thompson and it's
available online and it select Spirit
retailer so please welcome my my
boy
hi did you hear me say my blue way
instead of Michael but I like
it
everybody I love I love that it at least
happened with you cuz you're funny so I
was I literally instead of saying Cole I
said my bé instead of Michael you're now
mine yeah I want to be your I just
collected you I want to be
how are you hi Kelly Clarkson hi happy
New Year how was your New Year thank you
New Year is great I did a show what did
you do uh I hung out with the family I
was in I was in Miami it was
amazing uh I have four I have four kids
four kids do you sleep do I sleep I've
had four kids in my household at once
before that's a lot I'm too busy making
kids yeah yeah congratulations on that
okay do you ever you all make
resolutions or goals or anything do you
all do that yeah of course yeah okay
what are some of yours U Mine was go to
the gym every single day oh eat no more
like no more carbs no more sugars okay
um how fail
last last it to like the second yeah I
don't even set that goal anymore man I
don't even know I'm like don't why lie
to myself yeah yeah I could die tomorrow
I'm gonna die with sugar on my tongue um
so so I had this somebody told me this
crazy story did you CU polar bears are
well the most vicious and I heard that
you literally maybe had some alcohol one
time and were running on a beach where a
polar bear was eating there I was it
feels like a bad idea it was a terrible
idea it was in a movie with Barry Pepper
I love you know Barry Pepper Great
Canadian actor yeah um and uh it was up
in like Churchill Manitoba I think and
we were drinking at the rap party I
think God help me I all of this do I
think I think and uh and then I think in
the moment we're like you know we should
do
we should like race down the beach and
uh so me and him and another guy came we
came running down this beach and a guy
that lived there just started swearing
literally swearing at us and just
screaming I mean screaming bloody murder
buzz kill yeah yeah but cuz we didn't
realize we were running to our certain
death because there were polar bears all
down the beach and yes they the most
aggressive God but they're so cuddly
beautiful those Coca-Cola commercials
snug and so that is true I did that like
I sometimes I wonder about that how
close I was to being like a little polar
bear yeah well who would have thought
there were just polar bear nobody ever
hears that oh there's polar bears
hanging on the beach it just doesn't
happen well yeah up there was amazing we
used to rent these little Zodiacs um J
uh H oh my God why can't I remember his
name he's such a beautiful human being
James Cromwell yeah remember James
Cromwell he's such a wonderful character
actor you might remember him from babe
remember do pig yeah and he and I used
to go and yes give it
up give it
up I'm trying I'm trying to know are we
clapping for James or the pig or that'll
do or just that I remember all of the
things we're just happy in the new year
um but we used to for it was like 40
bucks and we would go and rent a zodiac
and go out and all these little beluga
whales would follow us good times oh
that's
beautiful yeah you know that's beautiful
it's important for me to get out of the
city and experience stuff like that for
my like emotional state it's so cool
everyone in your audience almost
everyone literally at the same time just
went a except one dude right
there you in the beautiful great good-
looking dude yeah and he did this like
this he's like that sounds horrible man
that sounds horrible wait I have to show
this picture cuz I think this is the
most Canadian thing I've ever seen this
is a photo from your childhood so those
are definitely skates and living room so
it's either is this Christmas or is it
just like a
Tuesday like what's what's happening I'm
not that's not me wearing the leg
warmers that's my sister but they were
yours she borrowed them from you we get
it no that is I dude I am so Canadian
are you kidding me I love it I'm that
was like and I remember how oh are you
kidding me how excited I was to get that
like anything I'm a huge Vancouver
Canucks fan yeah they're called the
Canucks yeah we and you know okay okay
but um anything hockey I I mean like I
was I would die for that that's a
vicious sport they get very angry no
they are missing teeth it's a lot of I
feel like it is actually it's very
redneck now that I think about it it's
very where I'm from I feel like I feel
like it it has such a code you know what
I really love about the game what the
humility of the game you know like in
basketball they score and then they do
like celebrations and stuff and football
there's a whole they set up celebrations
they get to the end zone hockey is like
the the better you are the the greater
you are the less celebrate you score and
you don't put your hand up you're that
cool so we both love I know Christmas is
over but look Sher came out with a
Christmas song and a record that I'm
obsessed
with that DJ play a Christmas song I'm
still listening to it it is my favorite
thing ever but you're on the Christmas
record you're on sher's Christmas record
yeah I mean you're kind of like Mr
Christmas so I get why she would you're
like perfect for like but wow I love her
so I listen you know she is the like
she's everything you
want it's a hero you want to meet I can
I tell you like I'm bragging but yes God
I we talk a lot and I message her and I
I send her like love notes I'm like hi
I'm so happy for you what are you doing
and you know like when we were working
on the record yeah she she would call me
and play the songs you know and then she
played the the the single I heard one
time one time and you and then we were
on the phone like a couple days later
and I was like you know that song's a
hit huh and she said like oh I hope so
and I said I said Shar I've heard it one
time and she said yeah and I say DJ play
that Christmas song
I night it's
C that's how you know oh my God I am
obsessed with it like I have not been
obsessed with this song since all I went
for Christmas you marai carry like back
in the 90s I that's the new one for me
when she so she called and she was like
when we talked first and she was like I
want to cover and I it was a song I
wrote called home I was like I think I
peed a little bit
Yeah because it was one thing that the
share I call a share the share yeah like
cuz you my my manager used to say you
know if you walk like a duck and talk
like a duck and swim with the Ducks it's
reasonable for people to assume you're a
duck I was like I want to swim with
share I want I want to swim with SH and
there's one of those things where she's
she's so normal and
crazy cuz she's such a legend and an
icon yeah but that's there's a lesson in
that and she recorded my song that I
wrote what I know that's pretty cool
yeah that's pretty cool so wait you have
a new whiskey you have a new whiskey yes
I do drinking it all
morning wait why whiskey it's called is
it Frasier and Thompson it's called f
Frasier and Thompson f&t because you
know what I love I do like whiskey I
like drinking me too I also like money
and I thought and you know I was me too
you know what's weird so my it really
started with my wife who didn't love the
harshness of whiskey and we we like
having drinks and stuff and so I was
like what if we do this together and
it's like a family thing and we create
something that it's yummy and sweet and
smooth like your voice yeah oh my God so
wait so what's the meaning behind the
name is it two I heard is it two Riv
that make me that's my grandpa my
grandpa was the he's the reason I I do
this he's the reason I'm sitting
probably sitting here with you and uh
when I was a kid he used to take me up
in in BC we go camping and there was
this called The Mighty Fraser which like
a dirty kind of river beautiful and the
the glacier Thompson and we'd meet in
this Confluence and so when I when I
bought this company and I started
building this company they said like we
need a name and it was like bé or or
like some singy thing and I was like God
they're all so cringy like and then and
I was like What if I come up with
something that actually means something
to me and then and then like it matched
perfectly I wish I was smart enough to
think of this but this is a blend of
Canadian and American whiskey this is
Like Heaven Hill it's the first time
this beautiful company that's been
around for over a hundred years decided
to work with someone else like they'd
never let anyone in and they let this
little nerd Canadian dude in and so this
company I bought called Circa started to
blend this whiskey and that's why it was
this perfect name this Perfect Blend
what a story I love that and the water
HS yeah that's beautiful and now they
built a uh i' love that you had an
experience like that with a grandpa
that's so cool yeah he's that's I mean
he used to and he used to make Grappa in
the real Italian what's graa so he would
he had a wine seller and then he would
uh he would make his moonshine oh so
with your bottle though even with the
aesthetic of it there's little Easter
eggs right with you and your grandpa
yeah did they tell you that yes we do
our homework that's so I know it's
birthdays right yeah my he yeah it's
it's uh his birthday's on top my
birthday's on the serial number um
there's there's a lot of other little
Easter eggs that this my Grandpa would
have been so happy he would have loved
like he would have thought this would
have been the coolest thing what's like
the coolest thing since you have such a
great connection with it's like the
coolest thing he ever told you like
advice or anything well I just remember
like I so I would go every Tuesday and
Thursday and I'd hang out at McDonald's
with him and his buddies yeah we meet in
the morning and have coffee and all
right and then people would be like
they'd see me at the McDonald's and
they'd be like
no and then they come over and they do
pictures and some like early on I was
like oh they want another picture of me
and uh and he said Sunshine be worried
when they stop asking for pictures oh
and so um did he call you that that's
what he called me
sometime all right everybody up next
we've got a game inspired by Michael's
whiskey that you will lose but you're
going to be polite cuz you're Canadian
we'll be right
[Music]
back
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home